every Tuesday our ion money series looks
at financial issues Americans face this
morning we're focusing on the growing
problem of student loan scams as many
families deal with college financing
this summer the Better Business Bureau
reports an increase in fraudulent texts
emails and voicemails about those loans
here's just one example this is Carol
Duncan I'm calling in reference to your
federal student loan I need to discuss
your repayment options with some new
changes that have taken effect recently
so if you could please be sure to give
me a call back I'm gonna go ahead and
give you a reference number if you would
please have this handy when you call
back it just makes things a lot easier
thank you
sounds scarily official but it's not the
Federal Trade Commission would not
comment specifically on this call but it
says consumers with suspicions should
file a complaint at FCC ftc.gov and
contact their lenders directly CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger is
here with what else families need to
know Jill that sounded real to me
absolutely it's her inflections the way
she was talking exactly she doesn't um
you know - a reference number that was
born right exactly and what's
interesting is these calls their text
their emails they are promising to
eradicate your student loans now if
you're sitting there with $30,000 of
loans that's gonna catch your attention
I'm calling Carol back exactly and Carol
says you know there's some changes so a
lot of these interfaces are trying to
reference the fact that there is an
Obama administration rule now there's
new rules you should act now and what
they're trying to do is get you to pay
money to get them to release these loans
so when you call back what happens
well what when you call back they are
asking you to immediately give them
credit card information write a check
and what's important to know is that
paying any upfront fee or even a monthly
fee is illegal that is your biggest red
flag if you don't have to pay any money
to move to change the in terms of your
student loans you can do that directly
with the government they're also very
smart because what they're trying to do
is wrangle out of you your federal
student
ID number now we spoke with a very
well-versed person in the topic his name
is having leaven and he said these are
basic scams across the board but they're
now focusing around graduation season
and also the fact that there are a lot
of people who are getting kids ready to
go to college in February and at the end
of the summer what's the significance of
that ID number they're trying to get
from you so if they have your ID number
they can go into the federal system
themselves change some things but also
then contact you again and say we see
that your loan number XYZ is this now
you should pay us because we think we
have a way to make this better what do
you do if you think you're a victim of
one of these so first of all take a deep
breath there are a lot of places you're
going to have to do some work the FTC
complaint line so FTC government Bureau
the Department of Education you also
really have to be clear you must go into
the system and change that ID number
that you have been assigned because you
don't want anyone messing with your file
so are there some legitimate loan
services that could be calling you so
there are certainly private student
lenders who are willing to look at your
total loan portfolio and perhaps
refinance them also though they won't
call like that they would never call
like that and also they're not charging
you an upfront fee okay
so what you need to know is if you're
looking to consolidate or change the
terms of your loan you go to the federal
student aid website and there are a list
of things that you can do whether it's
consolidation or doing an income based
repayment remember changing the terms
could mean you're paying for a longer
time and more interest so be very
careful before you do anything
got it Jill always good advice when
you're at the table Thanks